josiah gray is going to take down the
bulk of the innings tonight but as an
opener dave roberts goes with the left
couple lefties at the top of the giants
order and so darion nunez makes his
first big league start lamont wave
junior stands in and off we go a pop fly
into shadow left field aj pollock comes
on and calls off chris taylor for the
first out tonight you always know it's
buster posey coming to the plate when
you hear those dodgers fans they just
love him in l.a hey if they're not
booing you you're not any good just
gotta walk in the giant side of the
first base runner
now here's mike
it's sharply
there this would be a 10 player second
and a double play to finish off the
inning what a play by albert poole the
screaming one hopper and he makes the
play
lands on the bag throws to second and
the inning is over old friend alex wood
who got off to a fantastic start this
season for the giants then really
struggled over a five-star stretch he
had an era around eight
but he's figured it out again lately
including his last start of the first
half seven innings one run against the
cardinals as chris taylor stands in
against his old teammate driven to deep
center field
chris taylor
absolutely pummels the line drive off of
the wall in center you need a double
taylor wow what a year this kid is
having so promptly man in scoring
position and here's justin turner swings
at that pitch and hits it to right field
the ostrimski is going to catch it
taylor will tag
and he'll make it to third with one out
dodgers have a good chance here in the
first inning and here we go max muncie
who has just tortured the giants this
year 11 for 31 with eight home runs oh
that that's a torch job right there
muncie
center to stop the storm max
when a player has that kind of ownership
on a team he expects this to happen so
the lead-off double the fly ball and
then the ground ball hit albert pujol
stands in on the ground to short and
that should be a double play you got
plenty of time with pujols running and
the giants do
turn two so time running scoring
position just like that here's alex
dickerson i've been impressed with the
way he's hung in there against
left-handed pitching dickerson ripped
that one to right field it is gone
dickerson slammed it a liner into the
right field corner and just like that
the giants take a two to one lead
that'll bring up donovan solano salama
to right
sprinting over mckinstry
[Applause]
imitation
outstanding play
pollock is a board hit by a pitch to
begin the second cody bellinger coming
up here's the pitch swinging and missy
struck him out with a high fastball
for a strikeout for alex wood
now austin barnes fastball struck it out
swinging high fastball two strikeouts in
a row for wood so two down here is
mckinstry 3-2 pitch as a slider struck
him out looking three
strikeouts in a row for wood inning over
this is the big story of the night for
the dodgers it's the major league debut
for their number one prospect highly
acclaimed rookie right-hander josiah
gray the one down here is lamont way
junior my way blasts one to deep right
field and he could just watch it it is
gone
and way to the backside of the bullpen
lamont wade jr my goodness welcome to
the big leagues josiah gray three to one
giants rude breeding from the top of the
orders frank simmer first one is a big
digger for jojo gray
zia grace first big league inning is in
the books so wood who had struck out
five batters in a row hits two dodger
hitters in a row and here's albert
pujols pujols hits a little chopper very
slowly toward the middle infield into
backhanded is solano he makes the across
the body throw to first the inning is
over zaya gray beginning his second big
league inning that adrenaline's gonna be
gone so his command now should be
improved breaking ball to get him
swinging back-to-back strikeouts one
going
another strikeout too gone he is
throwing a tremendous amount of strikes
for somebody in the first big league out
strike three and josiah gray in his
second big beginning strikes out the
side
josiah gray goes back to the mound for
the fifth three k's in his last inning
that's pretty nice second inning of work
tyro estrada to lead things off he
swings here at a high fastball and hits
one to center field it's carrying well
bellinger back all the way back it is
gone
wow tyro estrada with some power four to
one giants
and he kept the line for you strimski
yastremski blasts one to deep right
field this one is on its way and it is
gone
another giants home run and it's six to
one the giants lead top of the order
against alex wood long way to go in this
game the giants now lead six to
one the first pitch a ton
way back to left field it's gone
same way the top of the fifth begins on
the first pitch of homer justin turner's
out and i'm just guessing but after
being hit by a pitch on his knee he
stayed in the game but i'm guessing that
that tightened up a little bit runner at
first nobody out austin binds the hitter
barnes hits it on the line to deep left
field that's over dickerson it is six to
three two outs and chris taylor comes up
doubled and homered in this game he's
been the best hitter for the dodgers
tonight center field the spells back
there the spell's gone
a two-home run game and a one-run game
he is on fire another bit of a
concerning move here mckinstry moves to
second max muncie has left the game so
turner and muncie have both left the
game in a 6-5 game here in the seventh
inning dave roberts going back into that
bullpen to bring on joe kelly runners at
first and second for the giants with one
away
way up there
taylor waiting for it to come down it
eventually dies with the infield
firewood in effect
and posey retired for the first time
tonight two gone throws him another
perfectly positioned zach mckesty and
the danger is able to get out of this
gym in the seventh
six five to the bottom of the ninth we
go
on to try and close it out for the
giants tyler rogers back-to-back
now the dodgers have really gotten up is
a nice christmas gift as will smith
comes up as the pinch hitter smith has
had some big swings throughout his young
career
[Applause]
win back to within a game of first
[Applause]